the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
oh what the best thing about driving a
car in a video game is you don't have to
pay for car insurance Gran Turismo one
of the most popular video games of all
time is finally coming to the big screen
and I gotta hand it to the filmmakers
because they took a pretty cool approach
to telling the story because the movie
is based on the game but it's inspired
by a real person here's everything you
need to know before you go see Gran
Turismo welcome to Team Nissan
now on this race track we are going to
drive through a brief history of the
video game we're gonna take a look at
the man who video gamed his way into a
real racing driver's seat I know I also
didn't know that this really happened
the cast that's driving all the action
what that action will entail and the
people who made it happen in the garage
so fans first encounter the Gran Turismo
video game as a racing simulation that
really aims to emulate the look and
performance of a bunch of different
Vehicles most of which are actual real
world cars I mean the game was my hack
for feeling Rich for an hour it was kind
of like putting on a robe you know you
just like instantly feel wealth when you
have one on
I digress what I'm trying to say is the
cars themselves of course lends itself
nicely to a movie adaptation now the
game itself was actually developed for
the Sony PlayStation and at first Grace
the shelves of your favorite video game
store back in 1997. now I'm sure I just
sent some of you back to a very specific
time and placing your head so I'll pause
for nostalgic purposes
and we're back so since then GT has
become a series with eight games
released across PlayStations one through
five with the most recent coming out in
2022. get this 90 million units and
Counting has made this the highest
selling PlayStation video game franchise
of all time it's basically like the Fast
and Furious franchise of video games
Let's Race let's talk about the man now
though because like I said before this
long-awaited movie based on a game is
also inspired by a person who just so
happens to be really good at the game
his name is Jan martinborough and his
Gran Turismo skills as a teenager earned
him a top spot on a real TV show called
GT Academy which basically gave skilled
Gamers the chance at a real world racing
career with Nissan and sure enough at
the age of 19 Jan actually became the
youngest winner of the competition he
got a job with Nissan and is still
racing to this day in the Japanese Super
GT series I mean how Wild that this
actually happen and also proof for my
parents honestly that shut down my
dreams of becoming a professional Mario
Kart driver you know what they say those
who can't do teach so here I am teaching
haha okay anyways
so Jan was born in England and is the
son of a footballer if he can't get any
cooler AKA a professional soccer player
and his dad's name is Steve
martinborough who had a very lovely
career out on the pitch but also uh can
I get in on this family I mean damn
now speaking of family let's talk about
the people who came together to bring
the story to life the cast playing The
Legend John martinborough is our team of
dekui best known for his roles in the
Apple TV plus series C and the certified
fresh horror flick mid somar now
alongside medecui is our boy David
Harbor as Jan's trainer you guys
probably know him as Jim Hopper you love
him as Red Guardian but I gotta say my
favorite iteration is Santa Claus the
violent kind now we also got Orlando
Bloom starring as a marketing exec
that's based on the GT Academy founder
Darren Cox now Jan's Dad Steve the
soccer player yup he's in it too he's
gonna be played by The Legend jaimon
hunsu who we love and Jan's mom Leslie
get this is played by Jerry Hallowell
AKA Ginger Spice from the Spice Girls I
mean this movie really has something for
everyone now her acting chops date back
to the 1997 cinematic Masterpiece do not
at me on this known as Spice World which
still makes me wish that I lived in a
cool 94 us also is there a 1997 theme
here anyway Jerry's been in some other
cool stuff too like Jason Statham's
action movie Crank high voltage and you
know once you've dropped crank high
voltage into the combo it's probably
time to move on because it just cannot
be topped who's got my
strawberry Tarts now when it comes to
the actual plot of Gran Turismo we
definitely don't know every pit stop
that they're gonna make along the way
but I can tell you that it will give us
the story of Jan's Journey the Hollywood
version anyway from skilled gamer to Pro
racer with or without some Hollywood
drama and of course the movie is going
to be turning both ways to include
plenty of gameplay action and real car
racing action now before I head out I
have to tell you about the behind the
scenes of this Grand Adventure known as
Gran Turismo it's directed by Neil
blomkamp you may recognize his name from
the time that he directed and co-wrote
the sci-fi film District 9 and got an
Oscar nom for best adapted screenplay
and speaking of oscar-nominated writers
Gran Turismo was co-written by Jason
Hall who was actually nominated for best
doubted screenplay for American Sniper
and the other writer for Gran Turismo is
Zach Balon who co-wrote Creed 3 and the
upcoming Bob Marley biopic so let's just
say that this pit crew is stacked peace
there you have it my friends that's
everything you need to know before you
go see Gran Turismo in theaters August
11th my name is Perez thank you so much
for watching this video of course be
sure to check out our other no Before
You Go episode so you're all you know
ready to go before you head to the
theater or so you can just like sound
really cool at a party when you meet
someone who's about to see the film as
always be sure to rate and review this
film at rottentomatoes.com we love
knowing how you feel and think I will
see you next time
foreign